la délégation comorienne décident de
boycotter les jeux des îles
après le départ précipité des athlètes
hier le comité international des jeux
des îles décide de retirer les ihm et
les drapeaux nationaux lors des remises
de médailles
la présidente du département de la
réunion s'indigne de cette décision
qu'elle qualifie d'inadmissible
je ne peux pas accepter de manière
symbolique à ce que on enlève le drapeau
français c'est comme si on m'enlevait à
moi la richesse de mon identité je suis
française de l'océan indien
j apporte ma richesse et ça donne à la
france la france de la diversité cette
richesse mais si la france est diverse
la république elle est une et
indivisible et m'empêcher de mettre mon
drapeau ou bien de chanter l'hymne
national me dire que je ne dois pas le
faire dans un événement sportif sur une
très terre française je ne peux pas
l'accepter
la présidente du département a tout de
même mis un point d'honneur hier à
remettre la médaille d'or aux judokas
réunionnais emportant quand même le
drapeau français puis à entonner avec le
public
la marseillaise je suis persuadé que au
niveau des supporters qui étaient
présents comme au niveau des deux ce qui
concourait il y avait de la frustration
et puis peut-être aussi un sentiment un
peu de déception parce que c'est vrai
que des rencontres sportives c'est une
rencontre de convivialité de partage
alors moi quand j'ai pris mon
mon drapeau c'était j'ai même pas
réfléchi s'était d'emblée c'était la
réunionnaise française qui a deux
lettres qui s'exprime